et je poursuis avec Stéphane Duval
expert en droit de l'immigration au
cabinet Maker était trop bonsoir maître
Duval bonsoir donc on vous a invité ce
soir pour nous aider à clarifier
certains points quelques points en fait
au sujet de cette entente annoncé hier
tout d'abord la question qu'on se pose
et qu'on parle de la fermeture du chemin
à Roxane mais dans les faits des
migrants peuvent toujours entrer par ce
cette boîte passage depuis minuit
aujourd'hui ce matin en fait il y a une
entente additionnelle qui était revenue
dans le Canada les États-Unis on a parlé
toute la journée mais il y a pas une
fermeture littérale du post frontalier
en fait il y a pas de poste frontaliers
là il y a pas de fermeture de béton qui
a été construit pour empêcher les gens
de
traverser la frontière ce qui est
survenu à minuit c'est l'entrée en biker
du protocole additionnel en vertu de ce
protocole
il y a eu un amendement de l'Entente qui
était précédente et par cet amendement
là
dorénavant toute personne qui tente
d'entrer au pays peu importe que ce soit
par un poste frontalier ou entre les
postes frontaliers dont le chemin Roxane
seront sujets à l'entendre des pays
tiers sur et donc les agents des
services frontaliers pourront refouler
ces gens-là qui demandent l'asile s'ils
ne rencontre pas les exceptions prévues
à l'entente et au protocole additionnels
il y avait pas de définition
auparavant sur est-ce que le poste
frontalier c'était uniquement les
édifices qu'on connaît lorsqu'on
travaille lorsqu'on traverse les douanes
et qu'on va en vacances il y avait pas
de définition spécifique donc si on
était 100 mètres à côté de l'édifice
c'est ce qu'on était au poste frontalier
ou pas d'où le fait que le chemin Roxane
est devenu aussi populaire au fil des
années donc ces gens-là sont toutes fois
arrêtés par la GRC toujours ensuite des
agents des services frontaliers vont les
rencontrer ils vont déterminer s'il
respectent les critères ou si leur cas
correspond en fait aux mesures
d'exception que cette entente là qui a
été annoncé là prévois alors quelles
sont ses exceptions qui permettent aux
gens de continuer en fait leur chemin
vers une demande d'asile au Canada les
exceptions principales sont applicables
lorsque c'est un enfant mineur qui est
non accompagné alors un enfant mineur ne
sera pas refoulé aux États-Unis fait
partie des exceptions à l'entente et
donc seraient admis au Canada à titre
d'une exception si un demandeur d'asile
a des membres de la famille qui sont
présents au Canada et que le demandeur
d'asile est en mesure de démontrer qu'il
a effectivement des membres de la
famille et là quand on parle demande de
la famille on parle de famille quand
même élargi pas uniquement conjoint
conjointe il y a les parents les enfants
frères sœurs neveu sont tous des membres
de la famille pour lesquels un demandeur
d'asile serait
exempté de l'application
sont des gens qui détiennent déjà des
documents d'immigration permis de
travail permis d'études où sont
visiteurs au Canada où il y a des
exceptions spécifiques selon l'intérêt
national par exemple quelqu'un qui
serait condamné aux Etats-Unis à la
peine de mort pourrait potentiellement
être exempte également et en terminant
ceux sont refoulés qu'est-ce qui leur
arrive est-ce que habituellement on les
amenés dans des hôtels là on va les
ramener aux États-Unis est-ce qu'on les
amène dans des endroits où on leur
sécurité et t'assurer aussi
immédiatement par exemple c'est pas
spontané de la colle et que l'agent des
services frontaliers
conclu qu'il y a pas d'exhension qui est
applicable pour la personne ils sont
refoulés donc remis directement aux
autorités américaines alors
ils seront emmenés dans une voiture et
les douaniers les agents des services
frontaliers Canadiens vont les remettre
directement aux agents américains merci
beaucoup maître Duval d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci